iran libération au compte-gouttes dix
nouveaux auteurs qui va être relâché
valéry giscard d'estaing à londres
objectif améliorer les relations entre
l'angleterre et l'europe
anouar el sadate dans le sinaï un nouvel
appel à la paix ce soir dans question
dans ezer weizman possible successeur de
péter un monsieur bonsoir à la une de ce
journal de capitale pékin et téhéran
téhéran parce que d'une minute à l'autre
nous devons recevoir des images des dix
otages des dix nouveaux otages qui
devraient être libérés avant la nuit
mais tout d'abord la chine les images
sera maintenant nous commentait patrick
clément ont valeur de symbole d'abord
parce qu'elles sont la preuve que la
télévision chinoise avait été alertée
avec l'intention tout à fait avoué
d'alerté à son tour les autres
télévisions mondiales
de quoi s'agit-il et bien de la
condamnation à mort de deux frères
jumeaux accusé d'une bonne centaine de
viols à anjou près de shanghaï
condamnation à mort suivi d'exécution
pour l'un d'entre eux image
impressionnante
il fallait montrer au moins 20 personnes
dans le palais des sports de hanzhou sur
les parties en bois clair qui reçoit nos
véhicules est utile de basket sont
installés trois teintes autour desquels
les juges ont pris place
voici le meneur de la bande
le procureur va lire l'acte d'accusation
dans lequel est indiqué que ce jeune
homme confère jumeaux et une dizaine de
complices ont violé en quelques mois 106
jeunes femmes avec solennité le
président de la cour présente les uns
après les autres accusés indiquent leurs
responsabilités les peines que le peuple
réclame contre eux
quelques heures ont passé le jugement en
délibéré voici les sentences
condamnation à mort pour le meneur que
voici
des peines de 15 à 20 ans de réclusion
pour ses complices nous assistons je
vous le rappelle un fossé près de
shanghai ces jeunes gens au violet ça
ces jeunes femmes chiliennes barbie et
anti-putsch unienne pierre ou à la
lecture de leur condamnation la foule
applaudit
en france les procès se déroulent dans
un palais de justice en chine habitudes
sont semble-t-il différentes les
prévenus sont jugés devant plusieurs
milliers de personnes à la vision de
cette foule où sont pris comme d'un
malaise cela ressemble quelque part aux
jeux du cirque
mais pour les autorités chinoises il est
peut-être la volonté de faire comprendre
à leurs concitoyens que la loi doit être
respectée
ce qui n'est pas si courant souriant
mais surtout que chaque 900 millions de
chinois a le droit à une justice légale
jusqu'il ya peu de temps ce n'était pas
le cas
immédiatement après le jugement on
emmène le condamné à mort en chine
quelques karine mathieu la ville dans un
pré là où doit être exécuté il le sera
après avoir été mis à jouer nous
arrêtons ici notre commentaire regardez
oui c'est évidemment une démarche très
politique au mont où s'élabore en chine
nouveau code civil
et alors que vient de s'achever la
tournée européenne du président par pau
fait donc maintenant l'iran le suspense
poursuit à l'ambassade américaine
suspense malsain entretenu par des
déclarations contradictoires de la part
des étudiants et des responsables du
pays
seule certitude à cette heure trois
otages sont en liberté et en lieu sûr
lille ont quitté ce matin à téhéran pour
copenhague puis pour l'allemagne c'est
là que nous allons les découvrir
il s'agit vous allez le voir d'une femme
cathy 'grosse secrétaire et de deux
marines de race noire
williams farès et la de maple l'avion
avait à peine quitté le ciel iranien que
la maison blanche publiait tu as un
communiqué saluant bien sûr cette
libération mais aussi qualifiant d'
injustifiée la détention des autres
otages otages qui doivent être relâchés
habib le communiqué nous étions en train
d'entendre donc la secrétaire qui
s'appelle 4,6 goisses et qui se trouve à
l'heure actuelle en allemagne les
étudiants islamiques ont bien sûr
confirmé aujourd'hui la libération de 10
autres otages si noir et quatre femmes
mais à l'heure qu'il est personne ne
peut dire s'ils seront bien relâché eux
aussi doivent être expulsés d'iran et
ils ont tout à l'heure été présenté à la
presse les voici
merci santé dans les bras les uns des
autres
80 assis côte à côte pour la conférence
de presse de leur libération avant tout
leur désertion en effet perdu aucun
contact entre eux il était complètement
coupé du monde extérieur
hier soir les étudiants angevins donné à
khomeini avant de lire un message très
dur du chef religieux expliquant
l'occupation de l'ambassade américaine
et pourquoi les autres otages seraient
juillet pour espionnage
parmi les otages il devrait quitter
terrain dans la nuit les marines des
gardes de l'ambassade des employés des
secrétaires cette fois il y aura plus
d'autres libérations mais quelques-uns
quand américains qui restent prisonniers
des étudiants islamiques devraient
attendre leurs process pour éteindre la
forme d'un procès public afin de boucler
l'opinion iranienne sur la justice
américaine
oui philippe rochot lisez les iraniens
affirment que les autres otages doit
être jugé et peut être puni il s'agirait
là d'une décision très grave une
violation de la convention de vienne sur
les relations diplomatiques
autant dire que dans ces conditions font
de cette guerre des propos monsieur bani
sadr aujourd'hui les relations entre
l'iran et les états unis sont
pratiquement rompu at il dit ce réveil
du fanatisme explique peut-être en
partie le désarroi qui a gagné une
petite centaine d'officiers de marine y
règne actuellement en france
ils forment l'équipage de trois vedettes
de lance-missiles commandé par l'iran du
temps du shah et qui rouillent pour
l'instant en attendant une décision de
l'aïe est là à cherbourg leurs équipages
pour être bien rentrer à téhéran mais
ils ne semblent guère pressé pas
forcément d'ailleurs pour les raisons
qu'on l'on peut imaginer
bâle en crise c'est l affaire des
vedettes israéliennes qui avaient
appareillé sans autorisation dix ans
après celle à faire des vedettes
iraniennes et les normands ont pris
quelques précautions
les constructions mécaniques de
normandie n'ont donc pas de chance avec
les états théocratique
mais sur ce point délicat le directeur
des chantiers de cherbourg ouvre le
parapluie
nous recherchons actuellement avec le
gouvernement iranien
les modalités de paiement et de
livraison de ses vedettes ce qui veut
dire que depuis la prise du pouvoir par
lehman comme elie vous avez des
problèmes
je suis peut-être une coïncidence mais
enfin nos difficultés ont commencé à
apparaître au rang de leur évolution
ce que nous voudrions c'est que les
opérations puissent se faire d'une façon
simultanée contre les trois navires et
des pièces détachées qui sont à
cherbourg le paiement des sommes dues
sur les 12 vedettes lance-missiles qui
ont été commandés aux constructions
mécaniques de normandie par le
gouvernement de téhéran
neuf ont déjà été livrées elles sont
paraît-il opérationnel dans le golfe
persique mais il en reste 3 ici à
cherbourg 3 comme ceux ci qui est
derrière nous dans le bassin de carénage
on est en effet obligé maintenant de les
repeindre parce qu'ils ont séjourné
pendant neuf mois dans le bassin de
l'arsenal
chacun de ces bâtiments coûte environ 10
millions soit 1 milliards d'anciens
francs d'un malentendu d'argent existe
déjà en france si on voulait proprié non
n'envoyez pas d'argent et majeure partie
de cet argent on a envoyé à trets
l'événement existe un compte en france
paris et nous sommes prêts à payer
vous êtes combien d'hommes en tout ici
entre les officiers et marins
actuellement 80 et tout le monde est
disposé à rentrer en iran sans problèmes
nous sont pressés en entrant devra donc
tout ce qu'on raconte sur des demandes
d'asile politique ça ne tient pas debout
or se compliquer en fosse génie
formellement a donc une mise au point
qui s'imposait au moins de la part de ce
commandant iranien
enfin pour être tout à fait complet sur
le dossier sachez que le mexique se
prépare visiblement à une prochaine
arrivée du chat à à cuernavaca problème
capital à retenir ce soit notre
attention londres le quatrième sommet
franco-britannique face à face magath
sachets et valéry giscard d'estaing
entre des dossiers souvent épineux nous
allons y revenir en détail avec jean
claude renaud mais je voudrais tout
d'abord que nos envoyés spéciaux à
londres nous précise
l'enjeu de cette rencontre et nous en
détaille la chronologie tradition
militaire
aux bonnets à poils des scots guard la
vieille angleterre était là pour
accueillir valéry giscard d'estaing est
aussi madame thatcher la dame de fer que
ses compatriotes regarde avec admiration
aux craintes mais surtout qu'avec estime
dire ce qu'elle pense et faire ce
qu'elles ti les sommets franco
britanniques sont une institution une
fois par an ils permettent aux
responsables des deux pays de mieux se
connaître et de mieux s'apprécier c'est
le cas pour margaret thatcher et valéry
giscard d'estaing si comme le dit un
courant de sympathie est passé entre eux
dès la première rencontre l'été dernier
une compréhension qui permettra
peut-être d'aplanir bien les divergences
de vues la france pourrait si
l'atmosphère est bonne faciliter un
allègement des sommes que la
grande-bretagne verse à la communauté
européenne
à condition bien sûr que la
grande-bretagne jouent vraiment le jeu
de l'europe qu'elle regarde un peu plus
vers notre continent un peu moins vers
les terres lointaines de son ancien
commonwealth
c'est cela l'enjeu politique tester la
volonté européenne de la grande bretagne
l'entente cordiale qui compte trois
quarts de siècle at elle succombé à des
problèmes de marchés agricoles on avait
de fortes raisons d'en douter vous savez
et cette magnifique angleterre où l'on
voit tellement de rolls royce dans les
rues et en demande dans les magasins est
elle au bord de la faillite économique
comme on nous le dit ici on a aussi de
fortes raisons d'en douter
ce qui est vrai c'est que la
contribution financière de l'angleterre
où marchés comme elle l'est coûte cher
et que c'est un peu pénible à supporter
pour le citoyen anglais déjà un petit
peu éberlué par la rigueur des mesures
d'économies de madame thatcher donc
madame ça tu cherches tu dois d'insister
auprès de ses partenaires européens et
notamment après de valéry giscard
d'estaing pour qu'ils aident
l'angleterre pour qu'ils aident la
grande bretagne
une fois de plus mais n'y a pas que les
britanniques dans cette affaire il ya
aussi d'autres il ya par exemple les
agriculteurs français dans une
discussion difficile
alors soyons précis un sommet comme
celui ci ça n'est pas fait seulement
pour parler d' affaire de gros sous mais
il fait aussi bien entendu parler de
gros sous et quand monsieur giscard
d'estaing madame thatcher parle de gros
show et bien disons que le problème
charlelie cas
quel problème exactement et bien savoir
précisément la peine d'y aller voir de
plus près cette deuxième rencontre entre
madame thatcher le président giscard
d'estaing prend place alors que le
premier ministre anglais doit faire face
à des problèmes économiques préoccupants
la ménagère qui fait ici son marché se
rend compte sans conteste de l'inflation
dans la communauté européenne la grande
bretagne se considère comme un des pays
les plus mal lotis et c'est pourquoi le
grand thème développé ces temps-ci par
madame thatcher et celui de la
contribution de la grande bretagne au
budget de la communauté européenne près
de 10 milliards l'an prochain
some inacceptable et qu'il faut réviser
télé le plaidoyer britannique qui sera
avancé lors du sommet de dublin à la fin
du mois est exposé au cours des
entretiens avec monsieur giscard
d'estaing pourquoi une telle somme et
bien d'une part parce que la grande
bretagne arrive à la fin de sa période
transitoire d'entrer dans le marché
commun ensuite parce que n'ayant pas
tout miser sur la politique agricole
commune à cause de ses liens avec comme
un noël elle se trouve pénalisé les
règles communautaires font qu'elle donne
beaucoup et reçoit peu ce sont ces
règles que la grande bretagne pourrait
changer évidemment ses partenaires ne
sont pas d'accord le fait est que dans
l'aise dans les dents les arrangements
actuels la grande bretagne souffre de ce
grand déséquilibre n'est ce pas et nous
disons que ce n'est pas juste et qu'il
faut absolument le changer et madame
d'atg même insiste que ceux ci soient
changés à au sommet des chefs de
gouvernement de la communauté qui prend
la place
attablé dans la fin du mois et elle
cherche avec ses entrevues avec ses
entretiens avec le président de la
république maintenant c'est le dernier
rencontre bilatérale avant ce sommet
elle cherche à arranger la chose nous le
disions les dossiers qui encombrent le
pas de calais qui sépare la france la
grande-bretagne sont assez délicat et
pour l'essentiel agricole jean claude
renaud les passages entre la france et
l'angleterre la bataille de
l'agriculture communautaire se déroule
principalement sur trois fronts le
mouton le lait et la langoustine
premier dossier le mouton les anglais
importe de la viande congelée et bon
marché de nouvelle zélande ce qui leur
permet de vendre leurs propres moutons
en europe à des prix défiant toute
concurrence pour éviter la déroute de
ses producteurs
la france a fermé ses frontières aux
ovins britannique ce qui lui vaut une
condamnation de la cour européenne de
justice
mais paris n'en démord pas les moutons
anglais seront interdits tant que les
taxes sur la viande néo zélandaise ne
seront pas majorées deuxième dossier le
lait et le bain pour les anglais la
france produit trop de lait et alimente
la montagne des excédents de beurre qui
culmine déjà à 500 mille tonnes
messieurs les français dit on à londres
nous ne voulons plus subventionner le
beurre des petits déjeuners soviétique
il faut donc taxer tous les producteurs
de lait réponse de paris
d'accord pour revoir la politique
laitière mais en taxant plus lourdement
les usines à lait que les petits paysans
français
troisième dossier la pêche les anglais
veulent obliger les marins français à
élargir les mailles de leurs filets la
langoustine à paris on répond que les
filets français sont conformes aux
normes de bruxelles et on accuse
angleterre de mauvais esprit
communautaire en conclusion ces trois
dossiers brûlants en cash
un quatrième plus important car c'est
toute la politique agricole que londres
remette en question en exigeant une
sérieuse diminution de sa contribution
au budget européen
à dix jours du sommet de dublin madame
thatcher proclame nous voulons payer
pour l'europe quatre milliards de francs
seulement au lieu de 10 actuellement
une telle prétention et frais paris mais
aussi les autres partenaires de
l'angleterre
en fermant son porte monnaie londres se
met à l'écart et les discussions à
dublin seront difficile car l'europe
verte ne fait plus l'unanimité et b
parmi les atouts britannique le pétrole
le pétrole découvert au large des côtes
et dans l'extraction va bientôt combler
tous les besoins propres de la grande
bretagne en france on est à la fois plus
prudents et moins chanceux cela dit on
vient d'apprendre quand même que la
société elf aquitaine venait de mettre
la main sur un champ pétrolifère
d'importance à 30 km au nord de pau qui
lui permettrait selon toute
vraisemblance d'assurer
une production annuelle de 600 mille
tonnes de pétrole ce qui quand on
regarde la carte actuelle des gisements
français n'est pas négligeable
oui l'an dernier l'ensemble de nos plus
de pétrole a produit 1,1 million de
tonnes c'est le centième environs de
notre consommation le plus gros puis
français et parentis dans le sud-ouest
ici il représente une journée de la
demande nationale
cazaux dans la même région ce
l'équivalent de quelques heures de même
que l'ensemble de la région parisienne
vous le voyez si le forage de buros
vallier donne réellement des espoirs il
ne s'agira que de 2 à 3 jours de
consommation française au mieux et au
même moment ce matin abou dhabi a réduit
sa peu sa production pour des raisons
techniques
ça représentait 3 semaines 2 chez nous
c'est vraiment une autre échelle
mais ça ne veut pas dire qu'il faille
arrêter les recherches alors après la
terre la mer notamment la mer d'iroise
où s'achève actuellement le septième
forage baptisé y arbore malheureusement
les indices de pétrole découverts ne
permettent pas encore une production
commerciale rentable
reste le golfe de gascogne la
méditerranée bientôt au prix où est
maintenant le pétrole on se mettra le
rechercher partout mais dans ce domaine
vaut mieux attendre et se fier aux
résultats des forages que de crier trop
tôt victoire
la politique maintenant avec tout
d'abord les pilotes d'un conflit qui
couvait entre henry fils d'un président
du groupe communiste du conseil de paris
et la direction de son parti au
lendemain des élections législatives de
l'année dernière henry fiszbin avait été
assez critique à l'égard de la politique
du pc il s'était estimé sanctionné par
l'état major de la place du colonel
fabien
alors qu'un communiqué avait alors
annoncé qu'il se retirait pour raisons
de santé du secrétariat de la fédération
de paris il voulait être réhabilités
entre guillemets il a donc donné
aujourd'hui sa démission de la
présidence du groupe communiste à
l'hôtel de ville la semaine dernière et
dans les mois précédents georges
marchais lui demandait de reprendre sa
place au sein du comité central
et puis l'assemblée nationale
l'assemblée nationale à la veille d'un
débat qui devrait être assez animée
autour de trois motions de censure de
l'opposition
robert ballanger françois mitterrand
michel debré roger chinaud gaston
defferre et claude labbé seront les
principaux orateurs d'un débat qui
devrait s'achever sans que le
gouvernement ne tombe puisque le héros
r à l'exception de quelques députés
comme joël le tac a d'ores et déjà
annoncé qu'ils ne voteraient pas la
censure toujours de thil que ce débat a
retardé l'envoi de la lettre du chef de
l'état son premier ministre
par égard pour l'assemblée nationale je
cite l'elysée samedi au delà de l'aspect
politique des choses je suppose que vous
serez intéressé par les conséquences les
plus pratiques de ce budget 80
conséquence essentiellement fiscales
alors d'abord philippe sassier les
bonnes nouvelles par rapport au projet
initial
techniquement si vous le voulez bien les
deux premières tranches de revenus nets
imposables sont enlevées de 10% les deux
suivantes de 9 %
on avait prévu initialement 8% pour les
autres tranches n'y a aucun changement
concrètement qu'est ce que cela signifie
voilà les nouveaux plafonds des revenus
nets imposables le revenu net imposable
c'est le revenu qui figure en bas de
notre feuille d'impôts quand on a fait
toutes les déductions qui sont permises
par la loi dit 7450 français la première
tranche jusqu'à dix sept mille quatre
cent cinquante francs de revenu net on
ne paie pas d'impôts 18000 260 francs
deuxième tranche 20e 1140 34000 230
francs
maintenant comment calculer et son impôt
à partir de ces nouvelles tranches par
exemple vous avez déclarez vous allez
déclaré vingt mille francs de revenu net
vous êtes donc dans la troisième tranche
vous déduisez 17 mille quatre cent
cinquante francs puisque jusqu'à dix
sept mille quatre cent cinquante francs
on ne paie pas d'impôts et sur la somme
qui reste bien vous appliquer le barème
de la troisième tranche c'est-à-dire 10%
et vous pouvez faire tous ces calculs
pour les autres tranches au large et le
prêt 2006 louis 2006 environ dont cela
fait environ 260 car dans les bonnes
nouvelles ou alors logiquement les a pas
trop les rebondissements extension
d'abattement fiscal 10 % pour chaque
conscience du couple jusqu'à présent
chaque dans chaque coupe un seul le mari
ou la femme avait le droit à cet
abattement fiscal et bien monsieur bart
a proposé que cet abattement soient
offerts et omar sy à la femme c'est à
dire qu'en définitive il est doublé le
plafond passe pour cet abattement à 13
chiffres alors il faut lui parler de
l'epargne également parce que certains
avaient craint que les femmes nées en
pleine exonérées en fait une bataille un
petit peu froide mais une rude bataille
cette bataille
donné par ben vrai qu'il y avait un
amendement qui proposait de plafonner à
3000 francs les intérêts tirés des
livrets de caisse d'epargne par famille
n'aurait pas pu bénéficier de cette
exonération fiscale
au delà de 3000 francs non moi qui avait
été voté dans un premier cadet et voté
dans un premier temps une espèce de
confusion si vous vous souvenez nous a
dit monsieur bara qui a été suivie par
les députés qui s'étaient aperçus qu
effectivement c'était un mauvais tour
était joué les années que run donc il
n'y aura pas de plafonnement pour ces
déductions pour cette exonération
fiscale ce qui signifie à dire que tous
les membres d'une même famille pourront
continuer à voir un livret de caisse
d'épargné à mettre du sucre le maximum
de la somme qui est autorisé par la loi
alors maintenant rouler bonne nouvelle
maintenant les mauvais exemples et pedro
ce qui peut faire grincer les dents la
tva sur les terrains à bâtir pas de 5
28% à 13 32 % ça va faire tomber dans
les poches de l'état environ 900
millions ça c'est une mesure qui va
plutôt pénaliser ceux qui veulent faire
construire des maisons individuelles sur
des terrains isolés et puis la sphère
des alors là il va y avoir un petit peu
de chambardements dans les bas de laine
des français les bons du trésor et les
bons du trésor attiré beaucoup de monde
parce qu'ils étaient anonymes et que cet
anonymat et supprimer le prélèvement
libératoire un kama peu compliqué pour
dire quel est le taux d'impôt qu'on paye
sur les revenus qu'on tire des bons du
trésor
il est porté de 40% à 45% merci philippe
d'avoir été complet en matière sociale
maintenant les contrôleurs aériens font
une petite pause et donne en tout cas un
délai à l'administration pour faire des
propositions concrètes si avant demain
14 heures il estime qu'il ya matière à
discuter ils suspendent le mouvement
mais pour l'instant toutes les bases des
contrôleurs aériens ne sont pas d'accord
sur cette pause en attendant les
perturbations ont été encore aujourd'hui
très forte sur tout le territoire
une pose également dans la grève des
transports lyonnais la cgt et force
ouvrière appelle à un arrêt du mouvement
enfin chez alstom la cgt attac après la
découverte ce matin d'explosifs dans l'
usine après l'attentât contre le tgv le
train grande vitesse la semaine dernière
la cgt dans une conférence de presse à
tout à leur parler de provocation
patronage et estime avoir d'importantes
informations à mettre à la disposition
de la justice a déjà été dénonce ce
qu'elle appelle une machination
préparait dans les hautes sphères
retour à l'étranger d'abord pour vous
dire que le bateau île de lumière vient
tout juste d'arriver à phnom penh et va
donc pouvoir commencer à travailler
la sofres nous apprend que l'élan de
générosité des français n'est pas
retombée 20% d'entre eux sont disposés à
adopter un petit réfugiés 37 % à trouver
un emploi un vietnamien ou un cambodgien
et 49% à lui trouver un logement
il y a deux ans souvenez vous la visite
historique d'anouar el sadate à
jérusalem est bien pour fêter ce
deuxième anniversaire le président
égyptien était dans le sinaï auprès du
mont moïse anouar el sadate avait invité
beaucoup de monde il s'est retrouvé
pratiquement seul ni jean paul ii ni
jimmy carter retenu par la situation
iranienne ni mettra une biguine
souffrent pas même un seul délégué du
gouvernement israélien bref le goût un
petit peu amer ben lendemain de cette la
rédaction d'antenne 2 célèbre cet
anniversaire à sa manière c'est à dire
en se rendant en israël tout à l'heure
juste après journal pour question de
temps à 20h35 des reportages une analyse
et surtout un entretien de jacques à
bouchard jean pierre elkabbach et paul
nahon avec réserve hermann le ministre
de la défense israélien finale reitman
dont beaucoup disent qu'il est
aujourd'hui diana rain begins
l'homme fort de tel-aviv un corps
d'athlète un regard franc un langage
vert à 55 ans le général isr weissman
est considéré en israël comme l'un des
plus sûrs espoirs de l'après béguines il
est l'homme qui fut longtemps considéré
comme un faucon comme un dur parmi les
durs du grand israël et qui disait des
arabes au lendemain de la guerre des six
jours s'il s'avise de franchir le canal
et recevront la plus grande bastonnade
de leur histoire est ce le pouvoir est
ce la confrontation les clés réalité
israélienne comme ici dans les
territoires occupés toujours est il qu'à
partir du moment où le général weissman
prend le ministère de la défense dans
l'équipe begin
il change radicalement aujourd'hui
heather weiss man et l'enfant terrible
du gouvernement israélien il est l'ami
personnel du président sadate
l'interlocuteur privilégié de la maison
blanche
il est surtout l'un des seuls qui
s'opposent à la politique de menahem
begin dans les territoires occupés il
n'hésite pas du reste à aller sur le
terrain à hélium aurait par exemple sur
ces images pour expliquer aux colons
sauvages qu'ils
non pas le droit de s'installer sur ses
terres qu'ils oeuvrent en définitive
contre la paix un moment lorsque moshe
dayan démissionna il avait songé à
suivre celui qui est son ami et son beau
frère
mais réflexion faite ezer weizman a
préféré rester à son poste en réserve du
gouvernement israélien dit aujourd'hui
ses amis ceux là mêmes qui le
combattaient il y a quelques années au
temps où la colombie était encore faucon
en question de temps tout de suite après
ce journal et puis pour endeuiller cet
anniversaire des terroristes ont déposé
des charges de plastique dans deux
autobus à jérusalem un attentat qui a
fait onze blessés premières élections
législatives en nouvelles hébrides elles
ont été remportées par le vaps et un
partie anglophone qui bat nettement le
parti modéré essentiellement francophone
les jeux sont donc faits en matière de
prix antonine maillet goncourt 79 et
jean marc roberts lauréat du renaudot
antonine maillet un nom qui a déjà
souvent été prononcée sur antenne 2 son
roman fait le récit du retour au pays
des acadiens français du canada après
leur déportation par les anglais en 1755
à leur tête pélagie la charrette
ce prix goncourt est une sorte de
revanche après l'ouvrît de la france de
ses enfants la quête savez j'ai le goût
de vous répondre
mon père et ma mère vous êtes venger il
y à cette année trois cent soixante
quinze ans qu'elle acadie a été fondé
fondée dans une sainte parce que et
pourra 7 et voilà que nous fêtons de
nouveau avec un pic comme ça et j'ai
l'impression que pour la première fois
l'acadie qui est presque rendu à la
france est capable de dire merci ou
alors soulevée au congrès francophone ou
français les deux parce qu'il est une
science mais une force a grandi aux
dimensions de la francophonie qui est la
france outre-mer et qui la font circuler
dans le temps parce que c'est un sens
qui avait un petit peu perdu son sens du
16ème siècle que nous nous avons gardé
alors êtes-vous vous-même une acadienne
du canada
une canadienne de l'acadie une française
de l'acadie ou une acadienne française
bref qu'on est de vous de votre identité
culturelle c'est très difficile à
répondre parce que je crois que je suis
tout ça selon d
portion je suis une acadienne peut-être
avant tout mais quand on agrandit la
famille on y une aphasie française et
cet acabit française là c'est la chance
en amérique donc au canada au québec
alors dans un sens j'appartiens à la
vaste francophonie d'amérique du nord
version acadie à côté du québec
mais alors est ce que votre roman est
l'expression d'un combat politique est
un combat plus que politique il est
historique c'est un politique avec un p
majuscule c'est une lutte pour la survie
c'est une lutte pour les droits de
l'homme pour l'identité de cette petite
culture qui quand même se projette dans
une vaste culture telle à 116 et 7 la
figure depuis trois siècles et bien et
deux dans un sens appelé politique mais
je crois qu'elle est avant tout
culturelle
alors après ce que vous voulez dire
entre les deux meilleurs j'ai envie de
vous appeler pélagie et ça me fait
plaisir
et à ce moment là je vous invite à
monter avec moi dans ma charrette parce
que cette pélagie qui remonte toute
l'année des cas pied pendant dix ans
elle remonte l'amérique pour aller à
fond des vallées denis naissance de
nouveaux essais
cet acte a dit qu'ils allaient perdre du
sang elle c'est un combat de vie ou de
mort et je crois que nous avons tous
vaincus et puis lauréat du prix renaudot
jean marc roberts pour son livre les
affaires étrangères sera l'invité de
notre dernier journal c'est à dire à
23h20 et puis un autre prix plus
symbolique celui des créateurs a été
décerné à eric losfeld qui est vous le
savez décédé samedi soir
les lutteurs sera enterré après le voile
avant de passer à la météo juste une
petite précision parce qu on nous
téléphone toutes parts il semble bien
que les bons du trésor restent anonymes
c'est l'information donc dément ce que
nous disions tout à l'heure les
l'anonymat pour les bons du trésor
conserve demeure la météo donc pour
terminer ce journal un temps ensoleillé
aujourd'hui sur le bassin méditerranéen
est également sur le bassin parisien
d'ailleurs ainsi pratiquement sur tout
le nord du pays
temps nuageux en revanche sur les alpes
le jura et la bretagne
il a neigé au dessus de 15 100 m demain
et bien de la bretagne aux charentes et
au sud de l'aquitaine un temps doux mais
nuageux
avec des risques de pluie de la neige au
dessous de 12 200 m du mistral sur les
régions méditerranéennes mistral qui
chassera les nuages
sur les autres régions de la france
nuages et éclaircies seront votre lot
quotidien habitants du nord et du centre
prenez donc vos précautions
il ya en effet des risques de gelées
prochain rendez-vous avec l'actualité
tout d'abord question de temps à 20h35 à
23h20 je vous le disais le gagner
journal de paula mae puis demain à 12h40
cinquantaine de midi présenté comme tous
les jours par patrick lecocq
bonsoir à tous adam amateurs à